Hey flash fam it's Charlie.
This is going to be my mid season finale video so
much craziness.
So many comic book Easter eggs, so much mythology.
So just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet.
There's a new round of the flash ring giveaway
going on now to all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video.
Make sure you enable alerts so you don't miss
anything during the off-season, but I'll talk
more about what to be happening during the
break at the end of the video just so much
craziness in this episode is that your true
midseason finale, they just try to crank up
as much mythology as much big action and hard
as they could.
So there were a lot of like really touching
Christmas-y moments let's do top 10 WTF and
then I'll add a bunch of extra the should
be like 15 or 20 just because it was so much
stuff in this episode number 10 Julian Albert
flashback to India they tell the story of
how he found the philosopher's stone than
there slowly setting up.
The twist were they explain the dual personality
which is right out of the comics, so number
nine.
He finds the philosopher's stone, but when
Barry throws them in the prison.
He has no idea what's going on.
But then Barry reveals his identity and he
explains his back story in much greater detail.
So the thing here there so many Easter eggs
the paper that he wrote in college about the
philosopher's stone was written by Albert
Desmond, who is the name of Doctor alchemy
in the comics the Julian Albert is his name
on the TV show so Julian explains that his
sister passed away but then he saw a vision
of her the way that Cisco's been seeing Dante
in the episode telling him where to find the
philosopher's stone how to bring her back.
But then we learn secretly number eight is
just's savitar speaking to them from the speed
force trying to get out open it and we can
be together again open the box.
They don't really explain exactly how it is
that savitar can manifest this way, but it's
almost in the way that the speed force wormhole
aliens last season appear to bury as people
that he cared about, so number seven Jay Garrick's
speed force explainer I'm actually in a turn
this into another video tomorrow into like
a much bigger video because it was really
cool.
The way they included this mythology he says
it's an endless void of energy time and space
which is how savitar is experiencing the future
the past, the present how he knows so much
about them but just like the comics he's stuck
in their, so number six the comic book version
of this is that Wally West was the first person
to fight savitar they changed a little bit
of his back story for the TV show the turning
and more into like an ancient person like
apocalypse in the X-Men comics like somebody
who existed a long long time ago instead of
comic books savitar who was a Cold War pilot
till he was struck with the bolt of lightning
and became superfast but he still didn't use
the speed force in the comics so I'll explain
that in the second because savitar's powers
in the comics are little bit different from
what the TV shows doing with them, but what
happened in the comics is that Wally West
was able to defeat's savitar by taking him
into the speed force a place that he couldn't
get to an end up getting trapped there, so
became a prison for him until the first flash
rebirth.
The Jeff John's Road way way back where savitar
emerges from the speed force but it was really
only a cameo.
So like he comes out of the speed force in
the reverse flash has this secret plot worries
poisoned Barry with the negative speed force
that makes him kill any other speedsters that
he touches it sort of like poisoning the speed
force well.
So savitar dies and that's the last you see
of them so they taken that part, of savitar
story turned it into a Hindu myth about him
gaining powers via the philosopher's stone
and then turning into this speed God that
number five gets trapped in the speed force
by a future version of Barry like he's as
I am the future flash, so everyone was like
this he talking about the future flash from
the new 52 comics no just saying that he is
the future of what speedsters are what they
will become the savitar flashbacks that was
so cool so the human form savitar that you're
seeing here is supposed to be Daniel Cudmore
who most of you know is colossus from the
older Brian Singer X-Men films he didn't play
Colossus during Deadpool to just shows how
he got his powers from the philosopher's stone
and then became the form that he is now.
So who knows if will ever see human form savitar.
Again we actually never learned his real name
in the comics we only knew him as savitar
they never revealed what his name was before
he gave himself that name like he named himself
savitar Hindu god of motion.
See you can see why the TV show chose to make
it a Hindu mythological thing that wasn't
in the comics like savitar just pick that
name for himself but his power, so the TV
show kind of showed that he derives his powers
from the stone not from the speed force in
the way Barry does, that's also kind of a
comic book thing where he can move really
fast, he's a speedster, but he doesn't touch
the speed force like Barry or Wally West does.
So there was this big thing about sharing
giving and taking speed force transferring
it between people so that's what savitar did,
he just stole speed from other people.
He couldn't take it directly from the source
like Wally West could.
So what he would do is he would just like
take everyone speed.
So like Jesse quick loses all her speed, but
because of Wally's direct connection to the
speed force he's not able to take his speed,
the same way so that sounds confusing.
Don't worry.
It just means that, because he doesn't have
the direct connection to the speed force.
That's why he can't leave the speed force
prison on his own, he needs another speedster
to let him out, so number for Cisco drinks
the Kool-Aid I love this scene because it's
kind of of reverse of what happened during
the killer Frost episode Caitlin has to rescue
Cisco from himself, the same way Cisco did
for her.
So was really touching moment actually thought
that she was can have to use her powers on
but he was totally ready to vibe her ass right
out of the room like that look on his face
is just so intense.
Speaking of which number three Julian Albert
confirmed as Doctor alchemy.
Finally, when they take the mask off.
But then they explained.
The twist in order to get him to trust them.
Barry has to reveal his identity and then
through the course of the episode he comes
around he has Christmas with them.
Meaning the Julian is now officially on team
flash, so you can just look forward to more
scenes with him working at star labs and then
number two.
Speaking of working together Jay Garrick flash
team up.
I love the flash versus savitar seen so you
have Jay Garrick flash versus savitar that
was brutal then you have Wally and Barry versus
savitar just that crazy scene of watching
Barry just getting jumped around the room
on the monitor because they can't see savitar,
but that Wally gets there and he can, but
they did say there's gonna be a whole lot
more Jay Garrick team ups in the back half
of the season so we'll see him working with
Barry a lot more.
But number one WTF Barry gets kicked into
the future when they try to throw the philosopher's
stone back end of the speed force.
It has to watch Iris die to there been a number
of versions of the flash that it had to watch
evil speedsters of one kind or another hurt
the people they love just been forced to watch
it and then try to fix it later.
So if you live there couple big reactions
the people have the scenes like this where
you one, they just flat out don't believe
it like okay the neck in a kill Candice Patton
off the show still fix it somehow.
This is their ticking clock like there's no
way that Barry is totally gonna chill on this.
I know they ended on a very hopeful moment
there in their new apartment together but
this shit is going to bug the hell out of
Barry for the rest of the season like this
at five months in the future that's basically
the season finale.
So it's like saying this is going to be there
finale but that is so much other stuff in
this episode like when he gets kicked to the
future.
There's Infantino Street that's Carmine Infantino
just a big comic book creator and I almost
forgot.
You know tied for first Mark Hamill as the
trickster of earth three totally dressed as
the Joker Joker in everything but name.
He was a very small presence, just because
he so busy filming the Star Wars movies right
now but I'm so happy that they brought him
back on an even just so much more vicious
than previous versions of the trickster he
does looks like he is so much fun when he
gets to play the character so I would expect
that to happen every single year where he
comes back for at least one episode but I
would expect because they can use Julian now
is a telephone for speaking to savitar that
they'll do that again in the future but he's
gonna come back to haunt that they'll have
to be some twist where the alchemist, stone
finds its way into somebody else's hands otherwise
there be no way for savitar to get back into
the real world to kill Iris in five months
so is crazy is all that is.
I really love the moment where team flash
gives Wally his suit.
So for all of you who felt like they've dragged
on this Wally plot for too long he's finally
going to start doing kid flash stuff, so he'll
have a lot of fun when Jesse quick comes back
for those you asking.
I don't know exactly which episode is going
to be but is going to be sometime early in
the back half of the season the be a whole
bunch of flash family stub and yes there will
be a gorilla Grodd episode there were some
pictures from the set, so if you guys want
me to do a video on the accelerated man just
let me know in the comments is going to be
a whole bunch of bonus flash videos during
the break.
So don't worry.
Make sure you have alerts enabled so you get
everything, but let me know in the comments
what you want me to do videos about while
we wait for it to come back that's going to
be January 24.
So, I know that sounds like a long time but
a section out that long.
So what I'm to do if they don't drop the trailer
for the next episode I'm in a drop of speed
force prison savitar explainer video in the
morning before I do my Arrow mid season finale
video so speaking of trailer.
A lot of you are asking about the Spider-Man
homecoming trailer that was supposed to drop
Sauternes out like the people that made this
whatever came out and said no.
This is totally fake even though it looks
official.
So if we get a Spider-Man homecoming trailer
it'll probably drop with Rogue one, otherwise
I'm expecting the Super Bowl.
But if we learn anything I'll post a video
it was supposed to be a special agents of
shield post credits teaser that was like something
super special whatever that is all totally
do a video for it.
Let me note you guys think of the midseason
finale.
I do love the holiday episodes when they work
really well like they did a little bit a holiday
stuff like you see Caitlin use her killer
Frost powers to turn it into a white Christmas.
It is on a really hopeful warm note, despite
the fact that you know that there is a ticking
clock now five months in the future Iris is
totally gonna get it with a steel spike right
through the stomach unless they do something
to stop him.
So you can expect all kinds of very craziness
trying to figure out how to do that but I'll
talk about this a little bit more in my flash
video tomorrow, but he's going to have to
deepen his connection to the speed force in
a way that he hasn't done before, like in
the way Luke Skywalker becomes much more powerful
as he learns more about the force.
The light side in the dark side.
So get hype in the flash ring giveaway is
still gonna be going on week to week during
the break.
So no worries about that either.
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the arrow trailer for tomorrow's
episode and you can click here for all my
other flash videos you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys tonight!